[Music]
the world will remember this day
the Trinity test and the revelation of
the first atomic explosion to the world
was one of the most important moments in
the 20th century it was a massive
miraculous project that many thousands
of people were involved with it touched
government it touched science it had
huge ramifications for all sorts of
Ordinary People the Trinity test and the
development and the race and the fact
that it was all attempting to save kind
of humanity from fascism World War II
would be over our boys would come home
this is a matter of life and death but I
can perform this miracle what was really
interesting was going back and trying to
understand what these guys were thinking
and the terrible decisions that were
placed in front of them I don't know if
we can be interested with such a weapon
but I thought she's scared we live in
the world that we live in because of
what happened at Los Alamos why would we
go to the middle of nowhere for who
knows how long how about because this is
the most important thing to ever happen
in the history of the world
all through Humanity we've been blinded
by ambition and pursuit and then the
ramifications of something else that's
happening isn't it
I think that's why it's so bizarre and
amazing that Chris is making this movie
now we're seeing parallels it's a it's a
profoundly overwhelming experience
watching it it's not a history lesson
it's not telling people this is what you
must learn from this but I think it's
very clear it can reflect back on what's
happening in the world today when I
asked Chris what was interesting about
why he wanted to make it he said I
always found that very interesting that
when they were doing the Trinity test
they were asked what are the chances of
this going wrong and then it blowing up
the entire world chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for theory of
loan zero would be nice didn't need a
shorts what is that decision to just
still go ahead and do it it's an
extraordinary moment in human history
and I wanted to take the audience into
that room and be there when that button
is pushed and really fully bring the
audience to This Moment In Time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]